there's a reason
that the venice film festival i mean
wanted this movie
to
premiere
at the festival yeah great works of
cinematic art yeah
hi there i'm jamie lee curtis and i am
judy graham and we are breaking down a
scene from our new film halloween
okay here we go good luck everybody
[Music]
tommy
tommy you can't go in there fine
glory no i mean he killed marion okay
you're in the hospital so lori has been
injured and
tommy comes in because he's informing
her yeah but i have lied to you
and told you
that's correct
which is why
i have this look on my face of
shock because now the worst nightmare of
course is happening yeah he killed
marion and he attacked lindsay too what
karen we didn't know for sure i didn't
know what to tell you mom i just want
you to be okay
she knows lori knows what he's capable
of yes and i'm terrified that my mom is
gonna injure herself more because i know
you and i know
that she won't stop until he is gone mom
i just want you to be okay listen i just
want you to know when he gets here i'm
gonna kill him
because 40 years ago when i was a kid
you protected me
so tonight i'm gonna protect you so
halloween two oh yes oh yeah was set in
hospital and i think obviously that is a
bit of an homage i think it was
convenient to have laurie have a knife
wound in her stomach at the end of the
2018 movie which would
send us to a hospital you know the movie
takes place in a hospital but the
violence that takes place in the
hospital is not
michael utilizing these hospital
equipments that they did so beautifully
in the halloween two movie
it's really this setting when you have
an injured woman in the hospital and you
have somebody coming to kill her and you
have a mob of people descending on that
hospital believing that michael is there
you have these cross purposes you have
michael trying to get there to kill lori
you have laurie's family trying to
protect her and you have a mob
coming
who could you
they are smelling blood and so it's a
it's a confluence of
such rage and terror
and then for her this terrible confusion
and for karen this great moment of
bravery which is like i've got this you
can't do this mom you're injured you
can't
you have to stay here i've got this
i'm gonna go get our my dog really after
thinking you are a liar and crazy for
most of my adult life yeah nurse
you know i appreciate you but could you
get up please
like get out now
we had him
oh no the i will tell you the lighting
in this movie is brutal but so is the
violence so yes it's not about looking
pretty no
but we don't blame michael simmons our
awesome dp i do but you could have
helped us out a little michael
i blame him if you watch this
how did he escape i don't know
i don't know what do we do we don't have
the police support we fight
we always fight go find him tommy
you need to listen to me right now
well for me the beauty of this movie is
that laurie is rendered impotent
lori cannot
fight because lori is injured she's
she's gravely injured and there is a
transference
from
lori spending 40 years to try to keep
herself and her family safe
to now karen having to live with the
shame
the terrible guilt yeah that comes when
you don't understand you don't believe
someone
and then what they're saying is true
it's a terrible
terrible feeling
and then the transference of the
protection
of i will take care of you where the
adult becomes the child and the child
becomes the adult it's powerful
all right a lifetime of preparation and
for what
rey is dead
so many people are dead we're not
equipped allison's run off with crazy
lonnie elam people are losing their
minds look at us acting our parents
was but you know what i just remember
the emotion that i felt with you i mean
you can see it i love you so much
and you're saying mom i've got this
don't worry and we've got you've got it
it's beautiful it is fun to watch
without the dialogue i know it's better
this is an important moment in the movie
though because this is when lori finds
out that michael's still out there so
it's really pivotal actually
even though you know
we're enjoying watching ourselves
there are authorities who are trained to
deal with exactly this kind of this
there's a system
uh at the time i think we were talking
about
our system in haddonfield and watching
it now i feel like the system
has failed us
you know failing us i think it's way
more meta now
than when we were shooting this movie so
david gordon green has i think he might
be a witch he's like a weird
witch who can see the future
laurie originally
said f the system
oh
and the first draft of it when she says
mom there's a system in place for this
it's like a system but it's so but by
the way the system
is really
kind of the metaphor for the mob which
is that that's and that's not us no and
that's what's it's i think it's just
more poetic to say the system has failed
us it heightens the stakes like saying
like the system is like yeah you're
right which is why i guess david changed
it was it him or you because it was him
no i give him all of it
the whole thing
there's a system
well the system failed it's like a
horror opera yeah
it's on that sort of
visual scale there's it's a stylistic
opera
and
the level of violence is so ramped up i
could hardly watch it i mean it's it's
it's brutal
violence
but it's violent
because it's a movie about violence it's
a movie about mob violence it's a movie
about rage it's is as he transcends and
kills harder and
stronger and faster more thoughtlessly
and more thoughtlessly so do the people
he is affecting they fight back more
viciously and it in the trilogy it will
be
the loudest and the ending
is so shocking
that you're left going
wait what because that's what violence
and sort of shock does
it it doesn't end beautifully sort of
poetically with a beautiful little coda
it's boom over
yeah
and you're left kind of half breathed
like ah
oh
yeah
it's really i i i sat
like this
i i was like
oh
and we even
knew the story
it's it's it's it's beautiful it's so
beautifully made
a man couldn't have survived that fire
check out our new film halloween kills
it's available to watch now let's do the
opposite way you do it first and then
i'll i liked it but we rehearsed it the
other way i know but this is called
improv judy this is gonna be the
commercial on tv i know and i think
it'll be excellent i'd say leave it the
way it was okay i'm the mother
you